hey leute hat er sich nicht mitbekommen
das risiko die kira und der liebe volkan
und der zell und natürlich auch ich in
namibia sind und das hat auch einen
grund und zwar hauptsächlich ist groß
dass mir ewig hat mit steinen wie wird
und zwar hauptsächlich yamaha grund die
spendenaktion die rede unter anderem mit
seinem verschwinden livestream geworben
hat und dabei eine menge geld zusammen
gekommen und was mit diesem geld
passiert das wollten wir uns eben jetzt
hier anschauen wir sind jetzt so weit
fertig wir haben gerade ein paar coole
tore gemacht wir haben fußball gespielt
mit den kindern wir haben uns gehen die
ganzen räume angeguckt wie es gerade
produktiv an wippen manche schlechte
sprache auf jeden fall wir uns alles
angeguckt und es ist einfach unfassbar
mal live zu sehen was wolken und sein
team auf die beine gestellt haben unter
anderem mit euren spendengeldern so das
war es von mir so weit zu diesen
hilfswerk mehr könnt ihr auf jeden fall
bei revis video sehen ich sage euch
jetzt ein paar bilder die ich so einmal
zwischendrin auf unsere ganz auf
[Musik]
offen
bio leute das was von diesem
zugegebenermaßen etwas kurzen video die
meiste arbeit und das meistertrikot
dieses video
das hat mir natürlich schon alle
angeguckt ich muss jetzt nicht so wirken
sofort eine 5 minuten ausgezahlt schon
wieder zu ändern sind und wir sehen uns
am nächsten
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ja